I make a key Cameo appearance in one of
our new animated children's shows called
chip Chilla I play a talking dinosaur
toy and this is incredible footage as
well watch this you got that right brour
no way I will find anything valuable
around
here I shall defeat Captain Bronto for
he is weak and I am less weak
what wow what a staggering and beautiful
performance by me I only have one line
but I deliver it with such skill and
force in Artistry that it practically
brings you to tears this is what many
people are saying anyway at least it's
what I said when I watched that episode
with my kids last night and uh I'll be
honest that my daughter talked over my
line so I had to rewind it and play it
again and say everyone be quiet for a
second listen to this